a little more than 15 weeks ago in
december 2011 the samsung galaxy nexus
was launched on verizon a 4g lte phone
with hardware by samsung and software by
google so it's been my primary handset
since then and this is the 100 honest
review of the android phone that i
waited so long for starting with the
hardware the only real concern that
critics of this phone had at launch and
also the android haters was samsung's
plastic back and i'm happy to report
that it's still really durable it's not
a problem none of the glass on the back
has cracked it's still in excellent
condition and one other thing to note
was that shortly after i got the nexus i
picked up the 2100 milliamp hour
extended battery which is just ever so
slightly thicker than the stock 1800
milliamp hour battery but the difference
is definitely worth it and it's still a
very thin phone but i'll get to battery
life in a second but onto the front of
the phone which i can tell you has
proved to be the best feature of the
whole device is the 4.65 inch
1280x720 super amoled hd display
absolutely astounding it's that
beautiful having a display this big and
amazingly crisp pretty much a retina
display makes it a pleasure to use for
everything that smartphones should be
good at it's comfortable for me i have
big hands i think anything over 4.8
inches might be a little too big i've
enjoyed as small as four inches on the
incredible two and as large as 4.7
inches on the titan but 4.65 is
comfortable
and all of that is exactly what she said
but seriously this is still one of the
best displays in the business and
there's no denying that so let me fill
you in on the software side of things
this is a nexus device which makes it
exceptionally easy to unlock root and
customize the daylights out of and
that's exactly what i've done here i
realized it was downright silly for me
someone who likes to take advantage of
the customization of android to stay
with stock for so long so i'm running
android 4.0.4 with the aokp rom a franco
kernel that likes me overclocked to 1.3
gigahertz and let me tell you this thing
flies the rom is what allows me to get a
few notable ui changes like the
convenient toggles up here in the
notification bar and the customized
bottom navigation bar with the
persistent menu button and the kernel is
what makes it so stupid fast i mean it
feels brand new but like i said this
device is past 15 weeks old the dual
core processor is more than capable of
everything stock but the kernel really
takes it to the next level and
everything just feels liquid smooth like
i just got it out the box it opens abs
quickly it closes them quickly even
crashes quicker honestly this isn't a
stable signage in mod or anything but
you will notice the occasional force
close and very discreet actions
somewhere deep in the os but you'll be
out of it in no time flat so it just
feels really great i actually tried to
get this thing to lag and as you can see
here
no chance i mean i think you get the
point this phone handles ice cream
sandwich like a boss now ice cream
sandwich itself is pretty sweet if
you're already an android user it's
really easy to fall in love with the new
ui but if you're coming from something
silly simple like windows phone or ios
then yeah you might think this is a
little bit confusing sometimes so give
it a few days and you'll get through the
learning curve just fine the built-in
apps are great they've proved to be very
reliable especially i love google maps
which is really helpful for me someone
who goes a lot of places on foot and
google maps walking directions
navigation is pure awesome and let's not
forget the play store which is full of
great apps great third-party apps
constantly growing with notable
additions recently like instagram and
temple run and speaking of temple run
i'm not a huge phone gamer at all i'm
more of a productivity and utility
person but it's safe to say looking at
this that gaming will go just fine on
this beauty of your screen i think i've
made that point already and so will
movie watching and youtube video
watching when it's full screen 1280x720
it's just hard to get over how rich that
amoled display is it amazes me literally
every day some days i find myself using
the nexus to catch up on my youtube
subscriptions more than i do on my
tablet or on my computer also a major
buying point for some people on a
smartphone is the camera's picture
quality and i have an entire video
dedicated to this and that'll be in the
description right below that like button
but to sum that up it's pretty decent
the instant shutter is really nice
convenient and the front-facing camera
is great for google plus hangouts or
skype or even face unlock yeah face
unlock did you catch that unlocking it
with my face and there are just some
things that android does really really
well like notifications for example
it just doesn't get any better than that
it's an amazing system battery life all
day every day
and did i mention that screen so overall
the samsung galaxy nexus easily one of
the best phones i've ever used and i'm
really glad it's my on contract phone
i'm not saying i'm not looking forward
to stuff like the samsung galaxy s3 but
just little things about android like
for example the ability to go and look
at how much mobile data you're using on
your device little things uh maybe like
the ability to sync bookmarks from
google chrome the galaxy nexus is
absolutely a very nice device even if
you were to buy one today unlocked for
somewhere around 450
absolutely recommend it like i said in
the video one of the biggest reasons you
buy a nexus is because it's so easy to
unlock and customize and to use a custom
rom and that's definitely what i've done
uh using aokp here on android 4.0.4
other than that a brief summary would be
awesome display really really really
really fast and pretty much an awesome
all-around device and thanks for
watching this review video guys of the
samsung galaxy nexus hope you enjoyed it
give it a thumbs up in fact if you like
this video as that really does help out
the mkbht channel and i'll go ahead and
sign off here and i'll talk to you guys
in the next video thanks for watching
peace
you